I'm corn Janee with my family back home
in Brampton oh nice so you know your mom
can take care of that hair cuz your
mom's a cow right yes you know it you
know that mom do it looks good I
luckiest person ever and I saw because
your mom's gonna do that for you you
recorded this kind of like everywhere
over the course of three years what was
it like you know dipping out and then
dipping back in to do this role um it's
I don't know I mean it's difficult
because it takes it took three years in
this case and takes many many years to
do any type of animated film so it's
challenging because some days while I
was on tour I you know lost my voice or
I was sick and so you kind of have to
develop the character and adjust and the
script is always changing too so it can
be different this you know you got to
like readjust the lines and but I
thought it was one of the most fun
experiences I would I would do it even
if it took like ten years it was so much
fun
through the glass over the hedge follow
the rainbow too
[Music]
where my dreams peeking Josh uh sure I
watched this film with my kids on the
couch the other day and they were
howling the entire time and then when I
told them who Jane was when I told them
it was you they're literally the eyes
like oh because it just didn't well they
love your music and they love the
singing my daughter immediately started
singing the songs that you were singing
in the movie it's so cool I mean not
only the like the message in the movie I
think is something that I am so happy to
get behind because it talks about family
you choose in a typical family lifestyle
which is so important but it's just nice
to bring something to like families and
kids or just people without it being
like I'm Alessia Cara thing it's just
like a Jane thing and I'm just giving
I'm just a vessel for her which is
really fun and it's cool because I feel
like a lot of kids you know might be
inspired by her and it has nothing to do
with me but in a way I got to contribute
to that to you so it's cool you know
with everyone obviously being at home
and trying to find things to do
you're you know you're working on
manifesting things are you manifesting
more music they're gonna come out with
like several albums when we're all done
with this I mean on one end that's
definitely the hope I'm not putting too
much pressure on myself but um I'm oddly
finding like inspiration in all of this
craziness so who knows
probably like five albums who knows or
none I don't know